le marché médiéval est la principale et
presque unique attractions des fêtes
johanniques cette année des festivités
repoussé pour la première fois de leur
histoire de mai à septembre à cause de
la pandémie de coronavirus en 591 ans
c'est la première fois qu'on avait fait
reporter des quarante femmes les fêtes
normalement elles ont été purement et
simplement annulée 2020 devait
commémorer en grande pompe le centenaire
de la canonisation de jeanne d'arc et
son inscription dans le calendrier des
fêtes nationales des festivités ont bien
lieu mais sans défilé surtout sans
jeanne sur son destrier
il faut perpétuer les traditions donc
c'est très très bien même si elles ont
été déplacées que sa part aqpere un
petit peu de son contexte
c'est très bien je suis ravi que les
fêtes et puissent surfer malgré tout si
on prend chacun nos distances si on met
notre masque je vois pas hormis le temps
qui malheureusement n'est pas là tous
les jours je vois pas pourquoi les fêtes
ont dû être annulés je trouve ça
chouette quand même pour orléans
c'est important enfin c'est quand même
un symbole qui s'est quand même réussi à
maintenir quelque chose
malgré tout bas c'est important
habituellement près de 300000 visiteurs
se pressent aux fêtes de jeanne d'arc et
parmi eux beaucoup sentent orléanais
pour les heures les années c'est quelque
part le symbole de la libération orléans
n'a jamais cessé de considérer jeanne
d'arc comme sa protectrice
après avoir été sa libératrice donc
c'est une figure locale est à la fois
nationale et ce qui est intéressant en
relayant c'est que on a en quelque sorte
une association entre divers images la
jeanne d'arc historique
la jeanne d'arc de la libération et bien
sûr la jeanne d'arc républicaine les
fêtes johanniques auront elles lieu l'an
prochain d'une ne le sait le visage de
l'âge induit est déjà connu puisque
rafale qu'en fût a été reconduite pour
l'édition 2021